hey um obviously very tragic let's
switch speeds okay very tragic situation
happen if it happened in Memphis
yeah the young man who got killed by the
five police officers uh you were very
much you got arrested protesting during
the pandemic after the George Floyd
thing uh which was awesome Brianna
Taylor or it was for Brianna Taylor but
but I feel like that whole time
just the pandemic just is all mushed
together yeah and I think it was a
blessing in the sense of like it really
gave light to things that just always
are happening but because everybody was
just standing still and not doing
anything it's like no this is just
clearly super [__] up and it keeps
going on so I think it kind of helped
highlight and catapult the movement I
was going to ask you like
obviously
protesting is something that moves the
needle because it forces people to see
the ugly yeah
um two years removed from that what are
the things that you're kind of doing or
involved in that are you know kind of
that isn't necessarily on camera
um I think it's just one step at a time
right and it's just like whether it be
just donating to the right cause just
talk trying to talk to the people who
are in power to try to get it done and I
can do a lot more you know it's still
everybody could yeah for sure it's well
I don't want to sit here and act like
I'm Marcus Garvey you know or whoever
the case may be but um
I think it's talking to the I don't know
I actually don't know the answers
honestly I just don't know but we can
it's obvious it's a [__] problem
it's obvious it's a big [__] problem
but I think it's the step is talking to
the people that's in position I think
the police bro
you know the original police were slave
Hunters
like actually like the original police
it's a real this ain't the same [__] I'm
just making up like the original police
so the infrastructure is just [__] up
because the same morals and values of
the original police officers was for
slave Hunters so now 200 however many
odd 1865.
so 200 plus years since slavery was
abolished even in a Reconstruction Era
like
sorry for the history lesson and I also
want to make sure I'm saying the right
accurate as possible yeah so boom so I
said to say the original police were
slave Hunters so now
that [__] turned into this police
construct that we have now and a lot of
the same morals and principalities are
just embedded within the system so
that's why I think it's proportional
it's disproportionate yeah yeah it's
it's it's like if the system is broken
how do you tear it down and rebuild it
yeah you know what I mean yeah because
if you think about the Memphis thing
it's like it's a police thing like it's
like these cops are like they're they're
it's the it's the institution even no
matter what color you know I'm saying
black police is
just did something like that you know
what I'm saying so it's the institution
that they're a part of because the
origins of the institution comes
from racism 100 man